Istres à l'épreuve de grand oral du bac
instauré par votre prédécesseur votre
prestation du jour serait probablement
sévèrement évalué
aucune thèse dans vos propos par
conséquent pas d'antithèse et encore
moins de synthèse en réalité l'éducation
nationale prend l'eau de toute part vous
écopez la petite cuillère
non c'est pas des foutaises et
dans une sorte dans une forme de
d'improvisation permanente dont les
cobayes en réalité sont les élèves
eux-mêmes de leur côté vous le savez
bien les enseignants sont lassés des
annonces répétées ministérielles qui ne
remettent pas à plat l'ensemble du
système éducatif il est grand temps de
prendre conscience de l'incurie des
programmes de notre système scolaire qui
forme qui fabrique des générations qui
sont sensibilisées à des tas
d'événements à des tas d'enjeux
sociétaux tous plus importants les uns
que les autres mais qui sont incapables
de calculer un pourcentage et qui pense
qu'un Alexandra est un habitant
d'Alexandrie si vous pensez vraiment
qu'il faut changer cela proposer autre
chose que l’enfumage des mystiques je
vous remercie